hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory I'm
interrupting my regular upload schedule
to give you all some exciting news
regarding the newly released and
exceedingly popular Harry Potter game
Hogwarts Legacy since the game came out
players all over the world have been
experiencing The Wizarding World for
themselves embarking on their own
adventures and Paving in the way for
their own destiny the game's amazing but
if I had just one criticism of Hogwarts
Legacy or rather one thing I'd like to
see added its multiplayer functionality
many single player games throughout
history have been extremely successful
so it's not as though this will make or
break the game however fortunately for
us it looks like less than a week after
the game's release a multiplayer mod has
already begun development this
multiplayer Edition is not anything to
do with Port key games however as
they've explicitly mentioned in the FAQ
that the game is only single player
Hogwarts Legacy is a single player
experience and does not have online or
co-op gameplay
gamesradar.com released the following
article discussing a multiplayer mod
called the hogwarp which is being
developed by a group called The together
team the modding team that brought her
Skyrim together is currently working on
a Hogwarts Legacy multiplayer mod the
team of mod is known as the together
team has shared a video of a prototype
of the Hogwarts Legacy multiplayer mod
named hogwarp the current build of the
mod is already available through Early
Access via the group's patreon page
which is surprising considering Hogwarts
Legacy was only fully released four days
ago as our friends over at PC Gamer
reported the together team aims to make
Hogwarts Legacy playable with up to 8
players which is sure to result in lots
of magical Antics around the School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry right now though
the mod is still very early days in an
interview with PC Gamer one of the
modders yamashi said that those who
download the mod in its current state
have to expect something very Bare Bones
in back
as a fully working mod is still a few
months away the team responsible for
working on this mod also created the
Skyrim together mod which ended up
taking several years to fully develop
however I've got faith that Hogwart will
be fully functioning sooner than that
what do you guys think does this vastly
improve the game or are you just happy
with single player leave a comment down
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live